[Musica]
[Applauso]
ora sera tutti siete stati abituati
abituati a vedermi in questo posto qui
stasera dalla durò qualche bollettino
qualche conferenza stampa
stasera vi svelerò cosa si cela dietro
il mio essere interprete di lingua dei
segni
ebbene sì o una voce anch'io buonasera a
tutti e tutti sono susanna di pietra e
la modalità in cui mi avete visto
comunicare la modalità con cui io mi
approccio maggiormente e
come unico attraverso la lingua dei
segni la lis e
sia in casa perché sono una coda ovvero
una figlia utente di genitori sordi al
lavoro perché lavoro nelle scuole con i
bambini sordi nei miei servizi di
interpretariato con con i miei amici e
con l'associazione che si occupa di
figuranti con genitori sordi e
la lis è la mia lingua madre e fin da
piccola mia madre ha sempre tenuto ad
insegnar mela un po lei ci sperava di io
nascessi sorda perché temeva che non
potesse avere con me quel dialogo che
tra lei e mia nonna è sempre mi è sempre
mancato mia nonna era fiera del mio
essere
normale è la cosa più bella che dice la
cosa più bella che ho la cosa più bella
della mia vita diceva sempre sono i
nipoti e io mia sorella i miei cugini
durante le feste c'era un uomo a tavola
e le chiedevamo ma perché la ci guardava
un po sorpresa sempre con i suoi gomiti
appoggiati a tavola e diceva perché sono
nati normali giustamente suo pensiero
dopo due figli sordi
eppure mi chiedo anzi vi chiedo voi vi
sentite normali
per me lo era anche la mia famiglia da
piccolina perché mi piaceva così tanto
muovermi muovere le mie manine insieme a
mia madre si creava tra me e lei quella
comunicazione speciale silenziosa ma
quello che ancora era più assordante era
il silenzio che che ci circondava perché
erano gli occhi delle persone che ci
fissavano ci guardavano sorpresi
increduli
capita anche a voi di osservare le
persone chiedervi cosa facciano nella
vita io lo faccio sempre
e poi rimango sorpresa delle risposte
che mi danno e credo che questo avvenga
un po anche a quelle persone che mi
pongono le loro di domande perché il mio
era un continuo rispondere a domande un
po curiose banali ma a volte anche
fastidiose perché quegli sguardi a lungo
andare insistenti davano fastidio come i
commenti inutili
e quegli occhi sgranati di tante persone
insomma era un po difficile da gestire
non mi sentivo da subito diversa mi ci
hanno portato a sentirmi domande come
perché casa tua si illumina
per che tua madre a quella voce
ma quando piangevi lei come faceva a
sentirti
che bello però parli il linguaggio dei
gesti ecco queste erano le classiche
domande che mi si ponevano e già da
piccolino a poco a poco mi costruivano
la corazza per poter essere pronto a
rispondere a quelle che mi si ponevano
poi in futuro e quindi sempre pronta
perché nessuno mi aveva mai spiegato
cosa ci cosa fosse il mio quotidiano al
di fuori della porta di casa
mi sono ritrovata già da piccolina
rispondere a domande più grandi di me a
dare sempre
spiegazioni non solo alle persone
normali anche a mia madre perché tante
volte certi comportamenti non erano
chiari ero sempre un po in allerta né di
qua né di là sempre a vegliare che mia
madre insomma non soffrisse che non si
esagerasse con le parole insomma a metà
perché noi coda ci definiamo un po così
a metà
né di qua né di là quando sentivo la
parola sordomuto o linguaggio ecco ero
sempre pronto a dover correggere le
persone perché non si dice sordomuto c'è
una legge che lo specifica la 95 2000
del 2006 e in quanto poi tra l'altro mia
madre non rinnega la sua sordità anzi la
si definisce sorda e come se noi ci
dovessimo definire non sordi o per
quanto riguarda invece lavorano proprio
linguaggio perché la lingua dei segni è
una lingua viene parlata da una comunità
si evolve nel tempo ha una sua struttura
grammaticale ha delle regole a delle
configurazioni ed accompagnata dalle
espressioni facciali
una scrittrice coda scrisse un libro
diversa figlia di diversi e quando lo
scoprì open pensai finalmente qualcuno
che potesse raccontare ciò che io avevo
sempre percepito vissuto e forse a mio
nonno avrei dovuto dirglielo che si per
lei era normale ma in fin dei conti non
lo ero per lei era sufficiente che ogni
sera
parlavamo al telefono stessa ora stesse
domande e quando lei mi diceva mi
raccomando saluta mamma io sentiva mente
passava la cornetta mia madre e mia
madre li riceva ciao mamma sto bene se
fondamentalmente io mia nonna ci
prendevamo cura di mia madre te l'ho già
in qualche modo me lo ha fatto capire ti
senti un po genitore perché ti ritrovi a
chiamare il medico a chiamare in ufficio
a chiamare il commercialista ad andare
addirittura da due professori per capire
come raccomandava comandati a scuola
come era il tuo andamento scolastico
interessante
però erano contesti più grandi di me
parole che non conoscevo ero piccola e
mi chiedevo perché
eppure l'altro il normale poteva capire
la mia situazione non doveva essere così
difficile
invece no l'altro il normale non era
pronto non sapeva approcciarsi non del
tutto e come lui tanti
con la tecnologia poi tutto è cambiato
mia madre inizialmente comunicava
attraverso questo strumento simile ad un
computer il dts lei poneva la cornetta
su questo strumento e cominciava a
scrivere a battere a macchina scriveva
scriveva scrivevo e io ero samperi
accanto a lei leggevo quello che
scriveva per che comunicava insieme ai
suoi amici sordi e quando dovevano
concludere il discorso concludevano con
con un asterisco se lo portava anche in
vacanza perché era talmente forte la sua
necessità di parlare di rima di rimanere
in contatto con le persone
poi sono arrivati cellulari ricordo che
in seconda media io fui la prima ad
avere il cellulare
perché non avevo la possibilità di
fermarmi ad una cabina telefonica e
aggiornare i miei di quello che stavo
facendo anche se mi trovavo nel mio
quartiere
poi arrivarono gli smartphone e via con
le videochiamate tuttora mamma le devo
ricordare di abbassare il volume perché
altrimenti tu magari sta in una stanza
ma ti segui tutto c'è posta per te
dall'altra parte del cellulare
mia madre è sempre stata autonoma
indipendente
ovviamente tranne per la comunicazione
ha sempre varcato le porte della società
con fierezza orgoglio ha sempre
dimostrato quello che era il suo essere
sorda e nei momenti di difficoltà o
quando per esempio anche da piccola mi
sentivo ecco diversa debole a me bastava
osservarla e percepivo la forza che mi
trasmetteva era la stessa forza che poi
mi ha permesso di percorrere i percorsi
formativi di intraprendere percorsi
formativi che mi hanno portato a quella
che che sono oggi
coda come vi dicevo è un acronimo che
sta ad indicare children of the others
ovvero figli udenti di genitori sordi la
prima associazione al mondo venne
fondata nel 1983 in america la cui
fondatrice amilly brother e da lì a poco
a poco in maniera radicale sono state
fondate tutte le altre associazioni
negli altri stati nel 2014
qui in italia
cinque giovani ragazze ovvero io mia
sorella che qui con me e tre nostre
amiche coda abbiamo deciso di fondare
coda italia la prima associazione che
opera nel territorio nazionale che
riconoscesse il coda l'identità del coda
che potesse essere un punto di
riferimento per quei bambini coda e che
potesse essere invece uno strumento di
condivisione e di vissuto perico da più
adulti
un associazione è che appunto mette in
risalto quello che è il nostro essere
perché ci siamo sempre un po sentiti a
metà
a volte nelle nostre attività e bello
vedere come bambini coda difendono a
spada tratta i loro genitori insieme ad
altri nei confronti di altri bambini
udenti perché capitano sempre quelle
domande e un po ci sono questi genitori
che ci fanno presente di queste cose ci
dicono come i loro figli vorrebbero
intraprendere piccoli percorsi per
imparare la lingua dei segni è un po è
come rivedersi e quello che io da
piccolina mi sentivo diversa oggi vedere
loro è per me una rivalsa e quindi tutto
ciò lo vivo come una risorsa
tanti bimbi per esempio hanno anche
provato a rimirar mi durante bollettini
e questo insomma è stato bello perché
diciamo che le nostre attività sono un
po queste sensibilizzare i più piccoli
per per poi arrivare ai grandi
avevo un superpotere e non lo sapevo
avevo questa conoscenza ma la
condividevo con pochi con quei miei
amichetti coda con cui ho trascorso la
mia infanzia e la mia adolescenza
tante volte abbiamo fatto finta di
essere sordi
cc radunava moe utilizzavamo sempre le
mani
non so perché sarà stato forse un
desiderio
me lo chiedo tuttora
diciamo che si in effetti mi sento
diversa anche oggi e mi chiedo mi
interrogo spesso su questo perché una
volta che io valico la porta di casa è
come se entrasse a stretto contatto con
la realtà e mi cimento ogni giorno è
come se mi mettessi alla prova e la
pandemia per me lo è stato come per
tutti ovviamente ma quando l'ente
nazionale dei sordi mi chiamò per dirmi
di andare a tradurre bollettini della
protezione civile e le conferenze stampa
del presidente del consiglio è stata un
po dura
li ricordo ancora le strade deserte di
roma percorrere roma in dieci minuti di
macchina
bellissimo poi chi è di roma lo sa che è
quasi impossibile però le strade deserte
il centro deserto c'ero solo io e io lì
per lì non mi rendevo conto non avevo
realizzato di cosa se andare a fare si
era un servizio di interpretariato
ma
incrociavo quei pochi sguardi di gente
che era lì in attesa che cercava
conforto ma lo stesso conforto che loro
cercavano in me ero io che lo cercavo il
loro e vedere che a poco a poco i
giornalisti aumentavano sempre più
assetati di notizie perché poi gli
eravamo tutti un po così in attesa di
risposte
insomma non avevo realizzato subito
quindi stata un po dura
eravamo tutti in attesa di risposte però
dal momento che uscivo da lì e poi mi
mettono in macchina pensavo beh però un
po di me io l'ho trasmesso ho
sensibilizzato la gente a casa era come
tante volte mi è stato detto sei entrata
nelle nostre case ci hai fatto compagnia
a me questa cosa ha fatto davvero
piacere ha scaldato il cuore è un po era
come se del mio vissuto a casa vostra
arrivasse ad oggi devo dire che è
leggermente aumentata la consapevolezza
di incrementare l'informazione
l'accessibilità ma nel quotidiano nella
vita di tutti i giorni questo ancora
carente se pensiamo ad esempio alla
pubblica amministrazione ai servizi
pubblici agli uffici agli ospedali dove
gli una persona sorda si sentirebbe
ancora discriminata dove mia madre
ancora si sentirebbe discriminata perché
lì non sono io non è il coda che deve
intervenire è la società che deve
sapersi approcciare ed è sono le
istituzioni che devono saper dare ed
offrire un servizio accessibile a tutti
se mi penso con gli occhi del coda
ancora non riesco a dire finalmente
perché ancora c'è da fare però piano
piano qualcosa si sta facendo
ma l'ho potuto dire lo scorso 19 maggio
perché è stata riconosciuta la lis la
lingua dei segni italiana dopo la
ratifica delle convenzioni delle nazioni
unite sui diritti delle persone con
disabilità e dopo le pluridecennali
lotte da parte della comit comunità
sorda e di tutte le associazioni che
operano nel campo linguistico
scientifico ed educativo in europa
l'italia era uno degli ultimissimi stati
in cui non era ancora riconosciuta la
lingua dei segni
ad oggi stiamo aspettando il decreto
ministeriale
però siamo fiduciosi la sanna piccola
oggi ha occhi più limpidi ancora tanti
desideri e spera che sua madre possa
essere vista come una persona normale ma
soprattutto spera nella gentilezza
dell'altro perché in fin dei conti basta
davvero poco
grazie
e se riuscite guardate il film il film
che ha vinto il miglior il miglior film
che ha vinto il premio oscar coda
[Applauso]